Hello everybody, welcome to the wolf!
Oh my gosh!
Sorry.
Is that too much?
This title screen is already so...
Very cool.
But this is my first time playing this game.
I've never played this game before.
I don't really even know much about this game besides the uh
the steam description so um but it seemed very intriguing so
I am very curious about the story um I will play one episode
per video and yeah um some of you may know some of you may
not know but uh I was going to do the walking
I played and recorded I played and recorded episode 1 and I
truly did not like it so so I very quickly hopped to this
game but I heard many many good things about this game and
many many people asked me to play this game so here we are
playing it so let's not waste any more time let's hop into
the game yeah yeah yeah I'm really excited.
Ooh.
Whoa.
Oh.
Okay.
I remember there's like a whole thing too, right, about like
the company going out of business or something.
Some drama happened.
Something, something happened.
And we, it's in limbo season two.
Once upon a time in New York City, there lived a community
of fairy tale characters known as Fable Town.
hundreds of years, oh my god, RGB, hundreds of years ago
after they were exiled from their homelands.
Through the use of a magic spell called glamour, they have
protected their secret community from the mundane world.
Oh, Sheriff Bigby Wolf brings people together.
I think that's...
World 5 today, again, if you missed it, a record for the
day.
Hottest ever in June, 103 now, and that humidity looks low,
but remember, the hotter the air is, the more moisture it
can hold.
Yeah.
So 103 with 31% humidity is a lot more humid than, say, 73
with 31% humidity.
And it is muggy out there.
Ugh, muggy weather is the worst.
Oh, wait, are there no subtitles?
Uh, let me...
Oh, okay.
Oh my goodness, sorry.
Um, gameplay?
Invertwise.
Selectables on.
Okay, uh...
My bad.
Sorry, I should have checked this beforehand.
Display subtitles on.
There we go.
Okay.
The wolf among us.
Really messes with your eyes.
So we got little fable people.
That's so fun.
I would be.
I kind of always wanted to be in Cinderella where she cuts
off her toes.
$400 to the Bahamas.
$400.
does this play as like a noir I guess not so far it hasn't
but we have no we have no cool commentary sometime after
midnight Oh mr.
Toad mr.
Toad shit big B listen mate I know I don't look human it's a
problem I'll get it I'll just step out the apartment for
just a second to see what kind of damage this drunk shit is
doing just cut me a break yeah i'll get me glamour first
thing in the morning oh cross my arm i'm looking at a
three-foot toad i'm looking at a three-foot toad in a
sweater that's a problem if you can't afford to look human
you're going to the oh the fight it's as simple as that you
can't send me up to live with those animals no way you know
what i mean go to see a witch get a glamour Big B, they're
bleeding me dry, mate.
The quality of the spell goes down, but the rates keep
climbing up.
Do you have any idea how much it costs to have an entire
family in glamour?
The fact that they have to pay for him is so expensive.
I don't make the rules.
Oh.
I can't give you a free pass on this, Toad.
No.
My hands are tied.
I feel bad for Toad.
Mr. Toad.
Oh, Mr. Toad.
Too much at stake.
She don't remember that.
For it costs, it's worth it.
You don't want me catching you out of glamour again.
Holy cow.
Fucking hell.
See, this is what I told you about, Sheriff.
You're just gonna stand there.
Do something, Big B.
Before he completely tears up the place.
All right, let's go upstairs.
We'll go upstairs.
I should probably go handle this.
Yes, please.
Thank you.
New book of fables entry unlocked.
prick of shite tell me how to spend my money dad the lights
are shaking again what do i say you want a big bad wolf to
take you away no no then get the back inside oh my god rude
toad what is happening the big bad wolf i know you don't
want to see me huffing Oh my gosh, matchbook.
The phone's off the hook and everything.
It's basically full, yeah, I'll take that.
Take a look.
Take a good look.
Know who I am now?
Hey, look at me.
Get off of me.
We can knock.
We'll be polite.
Moshy-moshy.
Keep it down, please.
Oh, okay.
That works.
God damn you!
You know who I am now.
Whoa, whoa, hey!
Hey!
Oh, dang!
You've got something on your face.
Fuck, are you talking about you, stupid girl?
I'll fucking kill you!
Everybody, calm down!
All right, everyone.
Oh, dang.
Okay, we didn't even get it out of our mouth.
Oh.
What are you gonna fucking do, huh?
Oh, okay.
Get the fuck out of the way before you get the accident.
This is your last warning.
I'm crackling my knuckles.
Woody?
This is your last warning.
Is he?
You keep on like this.
I won't have any choice but to put you down.
Put me down.
He's going to the farm too.
You got a shit fucking memory, Wolf.
That's not how it went last time.
Is he?
This isn't last time.
Um...
What?
Oh.
Wait.
You gotta calm down.
Oh.
We're gonna take him to the couch.
I'm thinking of Pinocchio, that's what I'm thinking of.
Oh, dang, he punched him in the throat.
I'm gonna put him on the bed.
The bed?
Okay.
And a thrice.
And of course!
We're gonna wash his hair.
Oh wait, he's bald.
Oh, he's got a knife!
Oh.
I'm too fast.
Too speedy.
Oh my god.
Frick you.
Oh.
Back off, asshole.
Oh, wait.
And, wait.
Oh, my goodness, gracious.
Get his ear.
Fight it off.
This
is attempted murder at this point.
Kew, kew, kew, kew, kew, kew, kew, kew, kew, kew.
Ay!
Oh, my goodness, gracious.
You never thought that being a fairy tale cop would be so um
you should probably get out of here look i'm not leaving
until i get what's mine you're not getting shit i'll put you
on the ground be nice if you can't be nice i'm gonna make
you wait outside oh shit you bogged my jaw you bastard still
you talk
um so what happened what the hell is going on yeah what
happened a little misunderstanding that turned into a real
show don't worry you saw the best bits oh he's drunk too so
he probably doesn't feel it as much you know look this is
just the start of a shitty night for me i just need the
money he owes me then i can go what are you doing here i
think she just said it he owes her are sealed oh what's your
name what's your name whatever you'd like it to be handsome
don't make this more difficult mint phantom sorry sheriff
wouldn't want to add any difficulty to your night why was he
hitting you yeah he asked me if I recognized him knew who he
was I said I didn't he started beating on me then you showed
up started beating on him thought about cover it hun I'm the
watchman you are.
No watchman.
I saved Little Red Riding Hood from this monster.
I cut this fucker open and filled his belly full of stones
and threw him in the fucking river.
That's who the fuck I am, you stupid bitch.
Hey, what did I say?
I'm throwing at you.
I said be nice.
Yeah.
Or you wait out.
Sorry.
Come on.
Ah!
Holy!
I didn't think I was going with him!
I thought we were just gonna...
That's not our car, is it?
Ooh, the hole in the wall!
She's not dead, right?
Hey, Toad.
My car.
Oh, good, it wasn't our car.
Give me a second.
Not the lost count.
Take your time.
Make yourself comfortable.
How's your insurance?
So, uh, how good is your insurance?
Does he have any?
I can't be mad at you.
I called you.
When you come to help, I can't be mad.
Oh, he's mad.
When you help, things end up more fucked than they started.
Oh, I think he's a little bad.
Well, at least you're not fucking dead.
Uh-oh.
Wait, he's back for more!
The violence never stops.
Oh, ah.
Your jaw is broken.
Come on, dude.
Oh, mini-q, mini-q, mini-q, mini-q.
Mini-q.
Ah!
I know you're fucking in there.
What?
Oh, he wants me to transform into a doll.
Oh, I'm queuing!
I'm queuing, I'm queuing, I'm queuing!
Oh, my finger's getting tired.
Come on, everyone.
Oh What the heck
Call call him yourself, I think he's now dead maybe oh No
This guy is a tank
Um, what are you doing?
Wait, she's taking his money, right?
Leave him alone You can't be doing that I'm just getting
what he owes me You all right back there?
I mean, your eyes and the teeth.
You're not really supposed to do that, are you?
Not if I can avoid it.
Uh-huh.
Oh.
He's got pennies.
I mean, take it anyway.
The guy's got an axe in his brain.
He's not feeling that.
It's more from me.
He'll be fine.
I'll tell you, you fucker.
He's alive!
Let me help you.
I'll let her do it.
That makes two of us.
I guess it's a good thing.
Fables are hard to kill.
Good lordy!
That was craziness.
The ring she's got.
Ah!
I didn't know the sounds.
Oh!
ickiness I have a match I have a match hold on hold on I
have a match I light her cigarette here or I have a lighter
who do you work for really who do you work for these lips
are sealed these lips
Why?
Hey, you like my ribbon?
Wait, is that...
Wait, stop changing the subject.
Stop changing the subject.
Is she the girl that if you take off the ribbon, her head
comes off?
I can't help you.
She'll remember that.
I'm answering them the best that I can.
It's got a little kissy mark on it.
How cute.
I feel like we've met before.
Mm-hmm.
We probably have.
We all sort of knew each other.
at one point or another but things change I guess I guess I
guess oh
he's gone already totally stop we don't have to make any
more of a thing out of it than it already is he hit you he
hit you he needs to pay yeah he's got nothing to give
sheriff I checked besides Oh, that's true.
I just swung an axe into the guy's head.
I'd say we're even.
Maybe I should be arresting you.
I'm not going to be doing this for much longer.
So, now's your chance.
What's that supposed to mean?
Should we go into the farm?
I want to go to the farm.
Seems better than this.
This seems better than here.
How much was it he owed you?
A hundred.
Thousand.
It'd be bad for you to show up empty-handed.
Million.
Oh, yeah, true.
I'll be fine.
I'll give her some money.
Let's see, I've got...
It's 20.
48.
It's all I got.
It'll help, right?
It's okay.
I'll be fine.
You've done enough, really.
Just... take the money.
Okay.
I'm not trying to Riz her up or anything, but...
out of a bad situation back there thanks well she doesn't
say bad i'm still gonna need a statement i have to go drop
off what i have meet me back at my office then it's a little
late for an office visit sheriff i'll swing by your
apartment oh how do you know where i live in the smallest
apartment in the woodlands what everyone knows that good to
know why is everyone just he's like
That's harsh.
That's a little on the harsh side.
I tell it like it is when I can.
Maybe she likes me.
Hey.
Yeah.
I need to tell you something.
You love at first sight?
You're not as bad as everyone says you are.
Because she's the big bad wolf!
I'll see you around.
Wolf.
Oh my god.
This is like if Lord Farquad took over.
Or like Remaindus King, rather.
This is what I feel like the place would become.
The city.
I say took over.
He was already taken over.
But you know what I mean.
Oh, welcome to Fable Town!
Wait, what do you mean chapter one of episode?
Oh, okay.
Whoa, cool intro.
Whoa, the aesthetic of this game is great.
It really works with like their telltale's like artistic
direction that they do.
You know?
It really works with this.
I know some people also recommended the Borderlands game.
Which I also think...
Ah!
Oops!
Which I also think would fit, you know?
Which I mean, it already does.
Faith.
Episode 1.
The Woodland Luxury Apartments.
It's late.
We don't get it done.
time anymore.
Oh, this is the plaque.
Who lives here?
There's three apartments.
I wish they wouldn't advertise that.
Why?
Wait, is this our home?
No.
I thought we lived at the smallest place.
Anything over here?
Nope.
Someone's tailing us.
Oh!
Someone's actually tailing!
Little red?
Stay off the grass!
there's no walking on the grass no whites orders I'll be
sure to send her an apology beauty beauty hello big B like
sleeping beauty I wasn't expecting anyone I know this looks
a little odd but there's an explanation yeah why'd you hide
well I didn't know who it was you can't be too careful these
days no okay damn it i'm late for a very important date
please bigby for honest me you won't tell beast you saw oh
it's a beauty in the beast much as it is and it would just
make my life a lot easier oh i'm staying out of it please
look not whatever it is it's between you and beast oh beauty
and the beast beauty will remember I don't have time to go
into it right now I'll explain it all to you later little
town but I have to go quiet city it's not very quiet anymore
it's not what you might be thinking I you could have just
said I needed to go to the convenience store I don't know
what would you what would he be thinking that he's the she's
got a double life very dramatic she is sleeping beauty and
beauty in the beast great security we got here so I could
touch the suit of armor wait is Is this thing alive?
It doesn't wake him up.
Fly catcher needs to dust this guy.
Fly catcher.
Hello.
Wake up.
Hey.
You awake?
I shot that yo.
Grimble.
Probably for the best.
Grimble?
If you straddle him, that would do it.
Definitely wake him up.
Been a while since I got an email.
Well, check.
Seventh day in a row.
All I get is always a spam mail in the...
In the, uh...
In my...
In the maid cafe's mailbox.
Bee Wolf.
Anything fell off again.
Oh, no!
Wait, where are we...
Oh, we're 204?
G.
Rumble.
Wait, who else was here, actually?
I want to look at it again.
I wish it didn't go so fast.
We got the B-beard.
How is this going to go on?
We got...
Private, private, private, private.
Beast, Mr. Rumble says.
Security office.
Okay, I give up.
What else was around here?
Anything else?
Newspaper?
That guy's snoring.
Alright.
This place seems pretty nice.
I mean, it's a little old, but it doesn't seem bad.
I think?
Who the heck are you?
Bigby, hey, wait up.
Have you seen my wife?
Have you seen beauty?
Oh.
uh so have you I did yeah I did what when just now you saw
her just now yeah just a second ago being way so honest you
can probably still catch her you don't beast the truth well
I mean I'm staying out of this immediately Well, he has
stopped my elevator.
Okay, I just wanted to go back home.
Big base apartment in Fable Town.
It's called, so the glamour is so that people don't know
their fables, but...
Damn, I should have cracked a window.
But they live in Fable Town?
Not being very conspicuous, you know?
There's some places with weird funny names though.
Maybe it's not so out of place.
It's just a little on the news.
What?
I know.
Probably should disinfect whatever, you know, happened to
you.
What's in the freezer?
Ice.
Oh, not even ice.
Make some more.
Put some water.
Don't be lazy.
Put some water in there.
Why do I even own this?
What the?
Huff and puff and blow your house down.
The red light is great.
Bluebeard folder.
Bluebeard's file.
Huh.
Never trusted this guy.
Ooh.
Oh,
we got some leftovers?
Don't even remember ordering that.
Probably a bad sign.
How long has it been there then?
Who is snoring?
At least this still works.
Turn it on.
Should help.
Is it so stinky in here?
Ah!
Oh my god.
It's Colin!
Oh, it's a freaking pigsty in here.
I didn't expect a whole...
Oh, he's one of the piggy pig pigs.
Little piggy pig pig.
Oh, hey, I'm using Colin.
Wake up.
Oh, hey, Big B.
I'm in your chair, huh?
Yeah.
Come on, I'm tired.
I'm tired, Colin.
It's been a long day.
And then Colin's going to the farm.
He's some pig.
He's gonna meet Charlotte and Charlotte's whip.
This guy is terrifying to look at.
Can we can we not have him be a pig?
Got a smoke?
You're gonna make the pig?
He's gonna smoke?
Oh, no.
No, it's really Pinocchio.
Thanks.
A couple thousand more of these.
We'll be even on that house you owe me.
This has got to stop.
You can't keep sneaking off the farm.
Oh, he was at the farm.
The fresh air and sunshine pitch they sell you on is
bullshit.
I didn't escape out of the homelands to end up in some
prison, okay?
Don't send me back there, Bigby.
okay you haven't been there I'll tell you a pain in the ass
yeah tell you what I told toad and what's that I can't give
you a free pass lectured by the big bad wolf he must have
loved that that for me no the house didn't blow itself down
big B that's all I'm saying do with that what you will now
I'm not saying it's reason enough for me to have definitely
been offered a drink but uh it would have helped ease some
of the pain you once caused me yes it also would have shown
everyone how different you are now i'm taking a sip of the
water okay but nice i take it all back this is why everyone
hates you so mean i was just hungry it wasn't murder i was
hungry Yeah, well, I'm hungry now.
You don't see me tearing the flesh off of your bones.
But you would if you could.
I'm so confused about, like, the lore here.
But, uh, no.
Hates the wrong word.
Like, did he eat him?
They fear you more than anything.
You ate a lot of people back in your day.
But then...
I thought we were all supposed to have a fresh start here.
Yeah.
I can't change the past.
Kind of confused.
Well, you can't change people's memories either.
Look.
I'm not saying it's fair, but it's real.
People are scared of you.
I mean, look at your hands.
What's wrong with my hands?
Oh, don't.
Who'd you get in a fight with?
It was a...
A fable, right?
I'm sure you're not going around Punchin' Mondays.
It's my job.
Yeah, yeah.
Your job is to beat the shit out of fables.
He was beating the shit out of someone else!
Fuck you.
Colin will remember that.
Well, I don't care about Colin.
You think my job is easy?
You try keeping a bunch of fables from killing each other.
How do you think this all works?
I don't know.
How?
By being big and being bad.
Don't say that shit in front of people.
It's embarrassing.
Chuni.
He's a chuni, big bad wolf.
That's the attitude that gets you in trouble.
I'm being big and I'm being bad.
shitty to everyone you came across tonight no not everyone
not the pretty lady actually i don't know her name toad toad
mr toad okay how are his kids doing he was yelling at him he
was sounds about right i don't think we were that nice mr
toad but that's fine also i was not nice to beauty i riding
her out and we live a long fucking time I know you like this
whole lone wolf thing you got going for yourself but I've
seen the way you look at snow okay you're not fooling me
will you shut up no way well maybe if my throat wasn't so
parched I wouldn't have to keep talking wait that doesn't
make sense yeah that doesn't make any sense at all enough
already I haven't slept in two days I went out a second
story window and I want to get in two seconds of shut-eye
before I where you look?
If I give you this, will you let me sleep?
Yeah, yeah, all right.
It just went a little sippy.
Okay, I'll give him a drink.
You chose it.
He's so gross, though.
Why'd they make him look like this?
Thanks, Big B.
Oh, I regret everything.
I mean, I mean, I don't know what else I expected because he
has no fingers!
It's got no...
Hmm.
Who knows who this is my house?
Okay, okay.
Wait, is Colin still here?
Colin left?
Hello!
We have a peephole, right?
We should do that.
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Never mind.
Big B!
Does this know what?
Oh, yeah.
come with me
do you guys know that what was that show once upon a time I
think it's kind of similar to this but still fantasy sorry
but with all the what happened what happened what happened I
just can't get into it this second we need to hurry I can't
stand when people do this hi hello good morning or evening
you're just walking down the hallway you can explain what's
going on
these walls are paper thin oh she wants to come we need to
be careful we'll talk outside okay we gotta be okay i got
that okay can't be too sure then someone's not listening
somebody's listening oh just kidding they're not i got
completed chapter two of episode one what
is that somebody's somebody was oh Is it a security card?
No.
They were a person and now they're not.
They're back to being a little fable person.
Yeah, what is the security jacket?
Is he under there?
He's a mouse!
Oh, that's a head!
It's a head!
Never mind, that's not at all what I expected.
you knew this girl is she's not a monday right a monday who
was she i thought i knew everyone in fable town uh just
looks familiar maybe a working girl i can't place her she's
a prostitute a working girl a working girl i don't i mean
i'm a working oh oh she's got something in her mouth little
tongue sticking out the woodsman he attacked her I stepped
in and he threatened to kill us both no you don't think he I
don't think anything yet I mean with the axe though he could
have it's just who found her terrible yeah so who found her
I did oh she was just like this didn't touch her I grabbed
Grimble's jacket to cover her with Grimble then I came to
get you right away Rimbo.
No one else who's with you?
No.
Big P. Did one of us do this?
There hasn't been a murder in Fable Town in a long time.
Oh.
Well, the more reason we shouldn't start a panic before we
know what's going on.
I mean, they said it themselves.
It's hard to...
Have a look around.
We don't have much time before people will be coming through
here.
To kill a Fable, so...
I mean, I guess decapitation is one way.
golly i i think i expected a mouse
oops strange cut what did this to her oh it's not clean
either something very sharp or something with magic attached
to it magic she was placed here with some care what do you
mean you can see that someone didn't just toss her here she
was deliberately placed for us to find a threat what kind of
monster would do this they saw that you liked her
what is yeah what is that it's the numbers for the lottery i
really thought oh whoa oh it's a ribbon there's some kind of
symbol i knew the ring was important i I saw it.
I didn't recognize it.
Neither do I.
Well, I mean, she didn't have enough money to pay back
whatever, whatever, so...
I'm sorry.
This is just so surreal.
What do you want to do next?
Investigate more?
Well, you still have some time.
should keep investigating the area okay good idea yeah
there's some blood over there so yeah we got the ring the
door yeah let's look at the blood trail it leads to let's
touch the blood why are we doing blood drops of blood I'd
say it's been here an hour maybe does it since he's a wolf
do you think he's got like a good sense of smell.
We got a scrap of fabric.
No signs that it's been here long.
Let's take it then.
Yoink.
Fabric.
Looks like jeans.
Doesn't tell me much.
Doesn't?
Anything in a trash can.
Now, we lift it up and there's a Correct!
Just some loose trash.
Fence post has blood on it too.
Someone might have hopped the fence, got caught, then left
the trail I found earlier.
Oh.
Blood.
Still wet.
Sharp enough.
No.
Well, I mean, that means it's doing its job, right?
Well, I guess it didn't stop the person from coming in, but
you get it.
Anything on this side?
Hmm.
Nope.
Nothing.
Hmm.
Excuse me.
Excuse me, ma'am.
I'm doing very important work here.
Okay, I've secured the perimeter.
Ma'am.
Do you know this fabric?
what are you doing better to be thorough sure just hurry up
we don't have much time
we should move her before anyone shows up we'll find out
more at the business office she'll be in the books i'm sure
of it like literal books any idea what's going on how did
this happen why her We'll say, I don't want to say it.
It's not ready to say yet.
Yeah.
Fine, let's just get upstairs.
You left Snow unsure.
Wait, no, I thought that was...
I didn't want to say this as a message.
I'm going to have to tell Crane about this.
Because it feels too like...
Oh, I guess this is a scary situation.
He needs to know.
Candy's going to find out anyway.
So we may as well get out in front of it.
Just wait a little bit.
It'll just be worse if he finds out we held it from him.
Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I've got all the motivation I need to find out who did this.
That sounds reasonable, but I don't know.
I'll think about it.
I just don't want her in a fairy.
She's gonna do whatever she wants to do.
Crane's not what's important right now.
We need to figure out who this girl was so we can find
whoever did this.
Take this back to Dr. Swinehart.
He can take a look at it.
meet you at the business office I got a bag or something for
I don't think the jacket is like so you know chapter 3 of
episode 1 oh what's going on oh what are you blind what you
don't see there's a line I've been standing here a half hour
already you get to just walk in must be nice being the
sheriff I work here and what great work you do sheriff hmm
that didn't feel very genuine why is there a line anyway
what kind of office is this yes I see because you are the
one bringing this to me miss snow the one who so simply
stumbled upon this catastrophe on our very doorstep the last
thing I need with mayor Cole away is a Yes, of course I do.
Don't interrupt me, Miss Snow.
You asked me a question.
Why?
I brought you this news as soon as I could.
No one is to blame.
This is a disaster.
It isn't anyone's fault.
Instead of trying to assign blame, maybe we should figure
out how to catch the fucker who did this.
Oh, is that how you see things?
The deputy mayor did it appreciate.
You are the one charged with protecting the citizens of
Fable Town.
do so cost someone their life and the safety of the entire
community tell me you've been doing something are there any
leads suspect oh my god we just found out about it like
anything at all any shred of evidence you two know what the
hell you're doing the woodsman is a person of interest from
what we've been able to gather he was last seen with the
victim you named the woodsman as a suspect drunk rich was I
don't think it's him at all though nothing certain yet well
find him get him in here if that's all you have to go on you
two need to a handle on this situation quickly i don't even
know who bluebeard is the last thing we need is all a fable
town knowing there's a killer amongst us amongst among us
yes sir call vivian right this minute and let her know i'm
coming in early for my massage i will ew why do you hesitate
on that where is the bottle of wine you were to purchase
don't bother forget it can't do anything
unless she is we'll find someone who can do it yourself you
know what stop we'll get on it right away let me say my
words let me say my words you would have just pissed him off
more all right I know well that could have gone better well
I guess I should have listened to you and waited wasn't
gonna say it told you so You don't have to say it.
It would have been better to have more to offer to get our
ducks in a row Oh Crane doesn't like people smoking and
Never mind smoke away He gets a morning massage Who gets a
massage this early crane?
It doesn't really matter the time of day a mere scent of
stress and he's out the door Okay, but to be fair I've got
is is he gone yes thankfully i've gotten like well there's
like head spas and stuff in the morning oh my gosh it's a
flying monkey the wine why did he have it oh buffkin oh
hello miss snow buffkin drinking this early where did you
get that it was by mr rickabod's desk then don't you think
it probably belongs to him who cares maybe maybe
don't how are you today mr.
big B oh good lord um fuck off buffkin I'm sorry buffkin
buffkin will remember that I'm sorry buffkin I just wanted
to be a jerk you know so once I'm talking about there's
bound to be information on her here to be able to get her
real name from the books whenever buckton finds them in the
meantime poke around maybe the mirror can help like a magic
mirror this appointment squared away but yeah there's the
genius lamp it's like a room full of all the fable like
magical items and stuff let's rub the lamp wait magic lamps
are pretty much just lamps after the genie's been afraid oh
you can see him there's a reflection in the mirror that's
crazy what detail wait so the genie is freed rubber rubber
rubber oh dang i questioned it only due to the amount it
seemed a bit excessive this it's a tarot deck tarot i have a
tarot card jack run him back from appalachia or what he did
to get him well that's not what i have here is that i can
look through it again and get back to you okay strength i
guess it comes in all forms puppy i'll be sure to let him
know oh the tower actually i don't know anything about taro
so like the cards i have no idea what they mean you know
that one looks like 10 of What the fuck is this supposed to
mean?
Yeah, it don't look so good.
Oh, we're taking it, though.
Interesting.
I'm sorry, Buffkin.
I'm sorry.
Oh, she's the Director of Operations Assistant.
She really is the Assistant.
Oops.
Alright, time to use our magic mirror.
Mirror, mirror on the wall.
Oh.
the mirror hey magic mirror i got a question you know the
rule i don't have time for this just do it it'll be faster
your impatience is callow you're needlessly cruel but have
some respect for our history rules is that supposed to rhyme
mirror mirror if you're able tell me all about this fable oh
nice rhymes that's so hard no yeah i'm about two seconds
away from kicking a hole in you there's no need for that
fine of which fable do you wish to know uh buffkin show me
buffkin oh buff hey put down the bottle and get to work
still looking buffkin buffkin the woodsman show me the
woodsman where is he is he drunk again what you see is
complete the woodsman stumbles down a street no shit which
street i'm sorry bigby i can only show you what can be seen
why choose a different angle i don't know snow show me snow
white she's like right there you could look over your
shoulder much of a request she's in this very room i don't
know her name i don't know her name not yet anyway well
until you do I can't help you nobody right now well that's
not helpful please return should you wish to ask about
someone else or someone new okay
oh oh buffkin oh well I'm sure we'll get it all cleared up
okay thank you I think I'm buffkins number one fan and
number one auntie Love and hate are just two sides of the
same coin or something.
Ichabod.
I want to know, what about that guy?
I guess we don't want to see his massage, huh?
That seems powerful.
That seems like overly powerful to be able to just be like,
show me so and so.
And easy peasy.
Book of symbols.
Oh, we can find the symbol on a ring.
Right?
read oh I can't read wait is this the one no I don't think
so what I can't read any of this you can't read it you can't
read it you're so scary looking maybe it will brighten your
shitty mood a little unlikely what's that it reads mark of
house of the frog prince frog prince i can see it kind of
just a little bit oh what's this say what's it say about
that it says brickel bit in an older elfish hat what's
brickel bit a magic word what's it do makes animals shit
gold This looks familiar.
From the Acts of the Woodsmen, a druid blessing, actually.
Oh, yeah.
Someone bless that thing.
I only translate.
What else we got?
That's not it either.
I want to find it.
Oh, we found it!
I found it!
What does it do?
This is the one.
Where is this symbol from?
Which family or story?
That's an odd one.
Family name?
Al-A-L-A-L-A-R-O?
Al-al-al-al.
Oh, l-al-al.
Al-al.
I-al- Donkey skin.
Yes.
Donkey skin.
Also known as donkey skin, girl, also known as donkey skin.
Also known as ass skin.
Ah, prefers to go by the name Faith.
Poetic.
Yeah, buffkin, she's dead.
Stop laughing.
Is this a real fable?
There was once a great king with a beautiful queen.
the queen grew ill and had her husband promised to only
marry the most beautiful girl in the kingdom after a long
search it became clear that the only woman in the land that
could match her beauty was oh his daughter it is it's a real
fable she had a magic cloak made from the skin of her
father's prized donkey that would hide her beauty so she
could escape his kingdom eventually she married a prince who
could see past the magic cloak and knew her true beauty and
they lived happily ever after should I mark it miss snow yes
please and
what's her husband's name Lawrence Prince Lawrence Prince
Lawrence what was she doing we got what we came for was what
she was doing her name's faith she was married to Prince
Lawrence I mean that's more than we name was faith yeah oh
we should talk to the husband you think he did it well i
can't rule him out you know nothing would surprise me at
this point we can't rule him out i mean we don't know the
guy at all we don't know anything that's you know we just
gotta look we just gotta check what is this now donkey skin
any information on fables in our community will be somewhere
in these books we already know our name, but feel free to
have a look if you like.
Oh, this is it.
Oh my gosh.
It's a donkey skin.
I had this horseman.
Oh, that's the mayor.
That's so funny.
Wait, so everybody in town is on this one page.
It's kind of funny.
Yeah, take him down.
Take him down.
That's me.
Snow White.
Why are all the dwarves look so scary?
Beauty and the Beast.
The Piggy.
Mr. Toad.
Who's this guy?
I haven't seen Badger around for a while.
He likes his privacy, I think.
Mr. Badger.
Mr. Toad would like his a bit more.
Wait a second.
Mr. Toad.
That's not Mr. Toad's a wild bride.
Right?
Nice hat.
Let's say Mr. Toad, that goes...
Wait, that goes to hell?
Wait, Mr. Toad.
Mr. Toad is a wealthy, eccentric, and an impulsive character
from Kenneth Graham's classic children's book, The Wind and
the Willows.
Known for his love of adventure, particularly his obsession
with motor cars!
This is the same Mr. Why is my mouse moving?
This is the same Mr. Toad of Mr. Toad's wild ride fame!
The same wild Mr. Toad's wild ride that...
Why is my mouse drifting?
Which at Disneyland, there is the Mr. Toad's wild ride in
which you drive carelessly through the streets of London and
then you get arrested and you go to court and you break out
of court and you get hit by a train and die and go to jail?
I mean, hell?
I love Mr. Toad.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh wait, we can ask now the magic, wait, with the tarot
card.
What does that mean?
Oh my god.
wild ride i love that ride you know what this means tarot is
a backwards art i wouldn't put too much stock in its wisdom
bigby not when you've been so helpful provisions muddy i'm
as clear as a window
about this fable which fable do you wish to know faith show
me show me faith through powerful magic her whereabouts
concealed unfortunately for you these lips are sealed that's
what she said to me these lips are sealed it's not my choice
of phrasing baby it's simply the way this has to be what
What about Faith's father?
Show me Faith's father.
The old king.
Oh!
Guess that crosses him off the suspect list.
Prince Lawrence.
He's a prince, I think.
Show me Prince Lawrence.
Wait.
He's wearing vans.
Where is this?
Where's what?
You know where Prince Lawrence lives?
If he's a prince.
relocated in the south wrongs yellow building red window
shutters red frames yep that's the one I can take us there
oh snow white okay nobody right now anybody right now yeah
that'll have to do for now come on we're going over there
all right let's go let's go magic mayor is cool sorry I have
to get that well this is kind have like a hello woodland's
business office yes i he is hold on is it mr toad it's for
you how do they know i'm in here moshi moshi is mr toad uh
uh the car sorry about the car yeah yeah yeah it's fine big
b shit listen right there's a bloke upstairs going through
all the woodsman's things get over here big big before he oh
wait hang on oh is that running Don't you dare hurt him.
That guy's gonna go to... that guy's gonna go to hell.
What was that about?
Hard to say.
Something going on over at Toad's place.
What about Faith's husband?
Mr. Toad!
I don't know.
I couldn't really tell.
But he could be in trouble.
And we should go there anyway to search her apartment.
Toad might have to wait.
Was that her apartment?
I thought it was the Woodsman's apartment, no?
Whenever you're ready.
Okay, let's go.
Wait, what about the people waiting to talk to her and
stuff?
I guess they would be more interested in...
Did Toad say who was there?
Was it the woodsman?
Talking to someone else.
Oh, it's possible.
Whoever it was, it didn't seem like Toad was happy to see
him.
Oh my gosh, Mr. Toad!
Maybe Prince Lawrence can wait.
Yeah, he didn't see him.
He could use some help too.
Ah.
Well, where to first?
Seriously?
Big, big.
Shit.
Listen, right?
As a bloke upstairs going through all the woodsman's things.
You think he did it?
What's her husband's name?
I mean, that knife is awfully suspicious, but we're going to
Toad's apartment.
Toad sounds like he needs help right now.
Yeah.
Glass slipper shoes.
Okay.
I'm not looking forward to breaking the news to him anyway.
Wait.
Oh, to the prince?
Pfft.
Pardon me.
It feels like he's not gonna kill you.
care.
I completed chapter four of episode one.
And we ended up going out the window and I landed on Toad's
car.
You guys made a real mess.
Oh.
It's worse than the day.
Oh my gosh, it's such a huge hole.
Oh, the car looks so bad.
Somebody up there?
Oh.
Hey.
Wait here.
He's only got one way to go.
Right?
Wait, there's a door right there.
A bathroom?
Shit.
What?
Where did that guy go?
How could he have gotten out so fast?
Wait, he's gonna...
He's gonna be behind me.
He's gonna sneak up and attack me.
Watch your back.
Bigby.
I'm sorry.
That's enough, all right?
Just shut it.
Aw.
Sobbing.
Aww, poor kid.
I don't even remember half of this shit.
Should probably get that fixed.
I hope we have a good salary.
Uh, go downstairs?
Something else?
Oh.
Woodsman never did much reading anyway.
Nope.
what kind of asshole swings a lamp a big hole in the wall
alright let's go I meant to click on it but it didn't work
for some reason
can we oh mr.
Toad you're going to hell you're going to hell mr.
Toad I've seen your future
it many times actually i've experienced your future toads i
think oh be nice in there okay oh i mean what am i gonna go
i'm i'm i'm walking in there to uh to what
bigby and miss white surely you didn't come all this way
just for my bother You said there was somebody upstairs.
Sorry, Big V.
It's embarrassing to have to admit, but I felt it was
someone else in Woody's place.
There wasn't, though.
Not when I checked.
Nothing but a leaky drain pipe.
Imagination must have got the best of me.
No, we saw somebody, though.
I saw somebody.
There was someone, but they took off when we got here.
Is that right?
I guess your dad's ears have a year or two left.
Haven't gone totally to the dogs, eh?
you're going to hell what is his shirt no lily are you all
right oh he's fine miss white just stung his little toe
better swimmer than walker just like his dad uh-huh so i
guess you'll be taking off now no need to hang around here
anymore mr toad i'm sorry you came all the way here for
nothing but i'll leave when i'm ready i'll leave when i'm
ready toad i just want to check things out first the longer
you talk somebody was in your building so just stand over
there and shut all right all right i just don't want to
waste your time as so i have a seat i have a cup of tea a
cup a cup of cup of grown-ups am i right oh uh little toad
flycatcher said you had a pretty awesome insect collection
i'd really love to see it is it in your room
it has a weevil cool Wow cute kid little frog just mind the
upholstery while you're looking for nothing yeah sure thing
mind the upholstery what you like your face smash lamp what
happened now this happened fucking hell damn thing must have
fell off the you discovered something uh-huh the lamp just
fell off the table all the boy was faffing about playing
salts and salt fish who knows with the lad wait it's
unplugged though
did he like use it to hit his kid mr toad i will send you
straight to hell early
We still got a smell.
You bleeding?
Why?
Yes, that's blood.
Still fresh.
Oh, well, I'll cut me end.
Ran around like a tit trying to pick out a wrap.
Must have got some on the furnishments.
What?
What pieces blood on the wall?
It's awful, I know.
Sounds painful.
Oi, don't you go maverending now.
the wound didn't sit very long you know show me a baby I
suppose and a frog I was gonna say show you me your hand
uh-huh does he let the guy escape from
here uh-huh oh there's more scrape marks and everything what
is it now if it's blood you know what happened I there's
more here on the window so and what's that about no real
reason what just last night when I'd come out I was in a
downright dizzy me this guy's got an excuse for everything I
forgot the keys to this place and I had to climb in through
the bloody window really really scared junior off to death
uh-huh well if junior told him why didn't you knock and have
him open the door for you hmm that's right oh the poker has
blood on it too
oh this guy is what happened here the poker well it there's
more blood on the tip this happened before or after you came
in the window after after i was i was poking the coals and
it slid a bit
shit ugly thing if you're gonna say something out with it
made a fire and a heat wave in the hottest summer in years
toad so why would you be making a fire stay in this place
for more than a spell and a drowse will make you think
you're an assaulting tantra oh look it on so what's the fuss
i thought toads can dry out yeah no mate you're thinking of
lizard that's not true at all lizards also like the heat
toad talked his way out of that one no no we didn't oh my My
God, will you not make a big fath out of this?
There's nothing to solve here, Sheriff.
I'm telling you everything that happened.
Why don't you believe me?
Who got hit?
I mean, things happened.
I think someone was attacked.
It's a goddamn mess, Toad.
Yeah.
It's like after a struggle or a fight.
I don't know why you cover for it.
Yeah.
I know you're lying about something.
But I'm not...
And you're just going to make it worse for yourself the
longer you keep up.
the act yeah i'm not bullshitting you honest my bullshit
meters off the charts
oh he's looking at me all funny like wait uh okay mr toad i
think that's all all we can do is talk to mr toad never been
good with the feminine juries homebody stuff with my clumsy
hands get tough i know something's off here toad And I know
you know I can't leave until I find out why.
So can we please just skip to the end of the page before I
have to get mean?
Yeah, I'll send you to hell early.
You won't, Big B.
There's nothing going on.
I think I've looked around as much.
I'll look around more.
I think I've looked around everything, but I don't want to,
like, screw this up, you know, if there's something I
overlooked.
So somebody came in.
Oh, oh, I found more.
I found more.
Dust drain.
That more blood?
No.
Just a clean space in the dust.
Did you move something?
The lamp?
Oh, maybe one of Junior's toys or something.
I mean, who knows?
The lamp?
Oh, wow.
Okay, Sheriff.
Now what?
The broken lamp was here.
The broken lamp used to be here, right?
Just tell me what happened.
Nothing happened, mate.
Nothing!
And why did the lamp have to be there?
Of all the blooming pointless inquiries.
It's my own place.
Don't you think I'll know what happens today?
The mark in the dust!
The lamp was always over here, Toad.
It was over here, and now it's there.
The space in the dust is from where you moved it.
You can't tell it or lie.
Who fucking cares?
Bloody hell, mate.
Come on.
Get off with this.
Ah!
Have to keep looking around?
Let's talk to Snow White, I guess.
Or unless there's something else over here.
Maybe the kid will rat him out.
Though most people think they are.
Uh-huh.
How's it going?
Oh, it's hiding something, but I don't know what yet.
Did the kid say anything?
really he was really upset though earlier he won't say why
hmm something's going on yeah stay with the kid until I
figure out why all right mr.
toad I'm coming back at you I think Maul junior has a crush
on you go come clean toad or I know you're lying toad toad I
know you're lying about the lamp.
The lamp fell is old.
I bumped it.
Coming in from the thing.
The thing.
The lamp could not possibly have fallen, Toad.
You had it plugged in over here the whole time.
Someone ripped the lamp out of the wall and threw the thing.
That's what happened, isn't it?
Oh my god.
Just give it up.
This guy is so persistent.
There's literally nothing else I could get.
Paper, a lamp.
Talk to him again.
I'm going to get mean.
I've got to get mean.
Tell me what's up right now.
You know what happens if you don't.
We've already been through this, mate.
Intimidate him.
There's just nothing to tell.
Look around the room and see for yourself.
Everything has its explanation, you'll see.
Honestly, Toad, I don't know if I will.
And I don't know if I've got the patience to
reverse-engineer whatever scheme this is.
Big boy's in the other room, Big B.
Come on now.
We're friends, right?
I mean, I called you here.
Can't we just start over?
Oh, am I going to have to hit him?
You scared, Toad.
Wait, oh, there's a busted latch.
I thought that was the...
Oh my gosh, I thought that was the exit.
Why is the lock busted?
I thought I was telling you to leave.
That's why I didn't look at it the whole time.
Spotted dust and a broken lock.
What are you getting at, mate?
Oh, for Christ's sake.
A fucking lock's been busted for weeks, mate.
Right, it's just like everything else in this bloody
building.
Hmm.
Bloody hell, Bigby.
What's the latest a bit of you uncovered this time?
I left the tap water running?
Didn't shock the recycling?
What's the point of all this, mate?
Oh, yeah, then why climb in the window?
Why'd you climb in through the window, then?
The lock's busted.
Why'd you climb in through the window?
You said it yourself.
The lock's been rotten for weeks.
Ha ha!
You wouldn't have needed a key to get in.
Just what are you all about, mate?
After the state I was in, I didn't have me head.
That's all it was.
I forgot the fucking handle was fucking busted.
And I'll tell you what else.
It's embarrassing.
You're bringing all this shit up, alright?
So quit it with a third degree and all that.
Big, big.
Come on.
I'm begging for mercy over here, oh boy.
I was looking forward to another.
I should have just had him.
It's me and me, son, and you've taken up enough of a day
with all this...
They're sniffing around at me private belongings.
I'm sorry I call really I am.
But will you please, please, just bugger off?
Not yet.
Not yet?
No one thought anyone could be there wasn't any scrap.
So when?
When are you gonna leave?
I love that way of just like loitering us.
I feel like I'm on trial here in my own bloody home.
When you tell me the truth.
the truth toad yeah i've told you the truth oh my god this
guy is so persistent you lied toad these stories have made
no sense you didn't forget your keys you didn't bump the
lamp off the table you want to tell me what's going on she
doesn't think much of me i don't think oh i wouldn't
necessarily say that progress mr toad code you're bleeding
what he is how do we not notice that this whole time oh my
god how did we not know it was that butcher a tweedle tamo d
you gotta strip him down to the johnnies before you can tell
which is which who can barge in screaming about shampering
the woodsman aid or flotty aid i don't know oh yeah he tore
up the place beat me up when i said i'll do didn't have it
oh my god tried to go out the window but he pulled me back
in it's been a whole morning what did you tell him when did
you tell him nothing there's nothing he wanted to know
except if I had this thing that he wanted what was the thing
or would have told you I wanted to oh my god that's all that
it was I never thought you knew or miss white he'd come back
and kill my boy I even tried to give the bastard a coat you
wouldn't take it whose coat the girl the dad borrows things
from people who live here this guy is going to hell
sometimes steal nothing turn around here would astonish you
mate well i merely repossess what's been left behind well
we'll be taking the coat now if she has next of kin family
anyone wait so it's all right fetch him the fur it's the uh
faith's dress or faith's coat she loved it he's hidden in
the fireplace you can't be serious it's the donkey's skin
now I wouldn't wear it outside oh godish it's hideous it's
terrifying it reminds me oh what was that movie like the
outsiders or whatever the people wore like pig skins and
mysterious object what could it be it's an envelope fucking
hell co-series for my luck it's a map to some bloody
doubloons it's addressed to Prince Lawrence do you want to
try and give it to him or oh it's a good thing we came here
first then oh I'm opening it okay I'm curious I'm sorry
faith I read Prince Lawrence I don't know maybe Lawrence
does well it's been quite a surprising day for all of us as
an eight I mean it's a mystery.
We have to know what she said.
Twiddle, twiddle, twiddle, dog.
It was very nice talking to you, TJ.
TJ.
Uh, see ya.
Hi.
I'm sending Mr. Toad to hell.
Does it always go that smoothly?
That was smooth?
So, the princess now?
I wouldn't say so.
Marges.
Yeah.
It's our best.
lead.
Our only lead, really.
Yeah.
I thought she was so stubborn about it.
Lawrence's apartment in the South Bronx.
Early morning.
I don't want to stay here any longer than we have to, so
let's just pick an approach and stick to it, okay?
Okay.
Just humor me.
We need to question Lawrence.
We're here to question Lawrence.
Bump him up on the suspect list or cross him off entirely.
Okay.
What is it?
I just...
I just don't think he did it.
Snow doesn't...
But we still need to...
Isn't it usually the husband?
It doesn't even matter.
He could give us another suspect, another lead.
It doesn't hurt to question the guy.
Let's be for real right now.
Veef.
I too tag buildings with Veef.
Oh, the bloody knife.
Oh, that's...
What is a body?
I think we need to go inside.
I think we need to go inside right now.
Miss Snow White.
Avert to your eyes, maybe.
The door is open.
Don't just peep into someone's house.
Check if he's home.
I'm opening the door.
I'm going in.
Was that Kennedy and a chicken?
If it stinks, how long has he been dead for?
Wait, his vans.
Wait, he was in the chair.
In the mirror, no?
But also, this is a second murdered fable.
Oh, that's bad.
Wait a second, that's bad, bad.
This is a bad, bad, bad.
Was this one of those like pull down beds?
Whoa.
Hughes?
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Snow, go, go, go, go get help.
Go get Dr. Swinehart.
I'll stay with you.
She's...
No.
Let me go.
What?
Shit.
What are you doing?
Oh shit.
What is it that you're telling us?
Water.
Bigby, water.
Kitchen.
So why is...
Where's the kitchen?
Okay.
Water.
It's so dark in here.
What's in it?
What is this?
I'll pay the rent next week.
Pizza in the fridge.
Please do not look for me.
Goodbye.
F.
Did you find it yet?
Don't look for me.
She's just up and left.
If you have something to ask him, you should do it now.
Uh, who did this to you?
Who did this to you?
He's like decaying, but also...
Faith did?
No!
Oh no, there's no way she did it.
Yeah, he's just saying her name.
Oh, he's crying.
Oh, he's dead!
Do you still have that letter?
This seems kind of bad.
There's blood everywhere.
It's only two words.
But he died without seeing them.
Oh.
I'm sorry.
If you have anything to ask, you might as...
You should do it right now.
Guys, dies after...
Find whoever did this.
He had two sips of water.
how was he still alive I mean I guess because the fables are
stronger but like goodness how long has he been on the
ground for oh my gosh it looks like he was stabbed in the
head is that what it was like the guy was a barely alive
corpse there's basically a corpse let me his fans oh no we
have a gone to the
peels what are they prescription sleeping pills oh
what's this shell can oh did he shoot how he shot himself
maybe what
is it gunpowder this gun wasn't fired recently oh maybe a
week ago He's just been on the ground.
He's been decaying.
He's been a zombie.
That's a zombie.
No.
They'll be on the grip and the trigger.
Oh.
That doesn't really help.
I was going to...
Actually, I think we should keep it on.
No, the smell.
The smell.
This thing looks...
Like, sacrificial.
Yeah.
Maybe I should have come here first.
Ah!
Sharp.
There's blood on the blade.
No.
I just don't understand.
Why would someone want to kill me?
He still would have died, no, like, immediately.
I don't think us going to Mr. Toads for an hour was going to
make a difference of this guy having been shot a week ago.
So...
Still a little sticky.
Sticky.
Oh.
That's a look at, and that's all we did.
Hard edge to this pool.
Ah, yeah.
Something was here and got moved.
That's why he looked at the bed.
Ah, I see, I see.
Oh, is that a photo of them together?
Oh.
When do you think that was taken?
Before all this.
Wow.
Crazy observation.
Bullet passed through the chair.
yeah the angle works if you shot himself oh my god
uh yoink anything over here all right let's get the bed the
bed okay pull I used to think these were so cool I had
always wanted one son of a wait how did it get pushed up
then if what is that I said I my dearest I never meant to
hurt you what my dearest faith stuck to the bed a little
yeah my dearest faith I never meant to hurt you and I cannot
endure knowing that I have this was for the best I'll see
you again love your devoted Lawrence They both wrote letters
to each other.
Hopefully they're together now.
Oh.
About all we can hope for at this point.
Oh my god, they're together and they have an argument.
And they're just like, he's like, Come on, babe, don't lose
your head.
Dugits.
Sorry.
What's this?
hand paperbacks old encyclopedia i know everybody in the
chat is laughing right now dusty no one's read these in a
while nobody reads anymore huh the woodsman didn't read it's
funny because they're all they're from books
what's in the closet jesus stay here no
Hey, stop.
Leave me alone!
I flung myself.
Oh, shoot!
I lost the QTE.
Oops.
Holy heck.
Oh my gosh.
We're just gonna leave it on that guy.
See.
Um, this?
What is that?
Oh!
Oops!
He almost gave you the slip.
What does that mean?
Oh,
we're fine.
We landed on a car yesterday.
We're just meeting him.
He's gotta go.
He came up to go down.
Does everyone just jump out of windows all the time?
Hey!
Don't follow me as you're covered in blood and everything.
Please help, Bigby.
We're on the same side here.
You...
Son of a bitch.
then make me run after you why why are you running who did
you run what why did you run fuck man because you chased
after me the fuck was I supposed to do you ran for what are
you talking about dead I know how it looks but I had nothing
to do with that you're covered in blood you're covered in
blood look I was just asking him about the girl that's all
when i mentioned her being dead he freaked out i think it's
someone he told him how is i supposed to know shit fucker
shot himself right in front of me oh he hasn't been dead for
oh okay wait did he you're looking for the woodsman right i
know where he is my guy says he's holed up at the trip trap
we can go over there right now The both of us.
My employer's looking to ask him a few questions, too.
And I'm going to hit him.
The fuck?
Come on.
Dumb.
Dumb?
Yeah, it is.
Look, it'd be much easier for you to...
No, I'm D.
He's dumb.
Oh, no!
Dumb is right behind us!
Ow!
Toeddle D and toeddle Dum.
Maybe I should have asked about his boss instead of hitting
him on.
Except you're lying in a dirty hour.
I'm not a great detective, are I?
I'm not.
Where did they go?
Where'd they go?
Well, after the one guy hit you and the other one finished
kicking you.
That explains the ribs.
Oh.
Then they jumped into a car and drove off.
We need to go to the...
Swing...
Guess we're out of options.
That place.
The trip track.
The trip track!
Then that's where we'll go.
I'll call a cab.
Thank you, Snowlight.
Completed chapter five of episode one.
Hey, I'm talking to you.
Every time I think I'm getting a handle on what's going on,
things just get more complicated.
Do it?
I don't feel like I have a handle on anything.
It feels like we're always a step behind.
That though, I can hear you.
The Woodsman is the only lead we've got.
And he was one of the last people to see Faith alive.
Getting some answers out of him will start to clear things
up.
I hope you're right.
Bigby?
Be honest with me.
Who do you think did this?
I don't think we have enough leads.
I know it's still early, but...
More?
I just feel a step behind.
What does more mean?
It's an uncomfortable feeling.
Bluebeard?
We haven't talked to him yet, but...
Tell me.
I don't think anything would surprise me at this point.
None of them...
I feel like Bluebeard has something to do with this.
I had the same suspicion.
Oh, stoically.
I don't know how or why just yet, but if you're asking, this
is his MO.
There's still a lot of questions.
What the heck is Bluebeard?
Find the woodsman, figure out what he knows, and then go
from there.
Makes sense.
That's probably the best approach.
my folktale was fables uh
good job you're doing a really oh sorry what was that you
first uh go ahead go ahead i didn't mean to cut you off no
it's go ahead it's nothing i just it so awkward why is it so
awkward all this today there are fables that are struggling
worse than i'd imagined we pay so much attention to the
residents of the woodlands you forget there's a whole
community out there to serve to have to turn to prostitution
i i wish there was more we could do This isn't how I thought
it would be.
But Crane runs things his own way.
You're doing your best.
It's all anyone can do.
Yeah.
Obviously, you don't know what I do all day.
Right now, I'm the gatekeeper, making sure none of these
disenfranchised folks are, as he puts it, wasting his time.
We need to kill that guy.
Oh, sorry.
I mean, we need to use...
Democracy on that guy.
The fables who walk in through the back door like Bluebeard,
we have all the time in the world for them.
You try and come in through the front door, through the
proper channels, asking for anything needing help.
Well, I turned you away.
There's a line of people.
I mean, to be fair, I cut the line too.
But I went in through the front door.
Well, that's not true.
Right.
We've had it worse.
Not by much.
Maybe this isn't for me.
I thought public service was pure.
You'll stick with it.
Stick with it.
You should stick it out.
There are fables that would give up a lot to be in the
position you're in.
And I think it's easier to change something from the inside.
Good job, Bigelay.
Yeah, that's how you fix things, no?
Sure.
Right?
Not the advice I imagined hearing from you.
I'm full of surprises.
I think they're going to get together.
Ooh, la la la.
Snow white and a wolf.
Maybe you should handle this one.
Like, it looks like the guy from Princess of the Frog,
Felicia, or whatever.
Three apples, Broadway hit.
Big B.
Yeah?
Yeah.
I...
Just be careful.
please you got it doll you too same goes for you ah I will
oh ooh
alright let's go into the trip trap what a fun name probably
a really fun place the trip trap bar it's gonna be awesome
in here
Oh, gotta fix our tie for this one.
I knew it would be awesome, it's carpool!
And...
What do you want, Sheriff?
I heard the woodsman here?
Uh, woodsman?
I'm looking for the woodsman.
Well, he's not here.
So I guess you can go now.
Look, I'm not even gonna ask where he is now, okay?
together I just want to know the last time he was here
that's all who the woodsman I'm being nice so try again he
hasn't been here for a few weeks don't say anything no maybe
I don't know but yeah he hasn't been here in a while if he's
been here at all which i don't know okay um does he tell you
when to close to yeah does he tell you when to close to no
and he doesn't tell me when to tell you to fuck off don't
have an attitude with me missy wow this place is 24 hours in
a day 24 beers in a case coincidence maybe this is like
This is like the...
Wait.
Does WJ stand for Woodsman?
Damn.
This is like such a man cave.
Eat, drink, fight.
My dad was in a band, and this looks like the type of places
that he would play at.
And then one day I watched the stand.
Stephen King's The Stand.
on TV and we went to the bar where he played at after that
and I was so scared of the world becoming infected with
everything I hid under the pool table and I just cried
because I was like this looks like a place in the stand I'm
gonna die here everybody's gonna get sick and die well I
mean I'm already dead but you know what I meant it wouldn't
be really fun if there were no human around and I don't know
maybe I thought ghost could catch it too huff and puff oh
wait no I have the huff and puffs wait so my fridge was full
of cigarettes I can buy more damn oh I can't buy more thank
goodness we got Grimble playing right now nah nah
Lib, we can ask about the chalkboard.
H?
Well, that'd be you, Holly.
So, who's WD?
No idea.
Because it's also the first letter in the name.
Yeah, I get it.
What is that photo of him?
Wait, we can erase it?
Why would we do that?
If you're not playing, then you don't mind if I...
Is it that big of a deal?
Hmm, maybe this will ruffle their jimmies.
Oh, pickled eggs!
Let me solve the mystery for you.
They're pickled eggs.
Oh, I know what they are.
I'm just trying to figure out why anyone would eat this.
That's a huge jar, too.
You can sit down and talk.
Grin?
Wait, yeah, there's this photo of him too.
Hello?
She's in the photo, too.
He irregular?
I don't know who you're talking about.
One with the bald head and the beard.
Never seen him.
You're literally in the photo!
Everybody's so...
She's like, I...
I ain't in a snitch.
I get it.
That's...
We got this from...
A lot of these walk out the door?
Yeah.
It's called advertising.
We got the same matchbook.
Get a refund.
Fuck you.
The word's getting out.
You'll never guess where I found the other one of these.
No.
I won't.
His place.
I...
everybody's so difficult who was drinking that yeah someone
who left well uh why didn't you dump it why didn't you dump
it if you want a cleaner place feel free to get the fuck out
of here oh now he speaks I'm sensing a very hostile tone
from you don't deny it I'm good at picking up on this stuff
You seem to be being a bit of a jerk right now.
You told me to leave.
Um, yeah, I only went next to you, baby.
I told you one right next to you.
Ooh, la la.
Where are you at?
I'll take one orange juice on the racks.
You know what I mean.
there's nobody in here you want a lime sure sure I think
they have some of the bar down the street oh good one that's
funny good one good one I think it's fucking hilarious it
was alright she thought she cooked with that one she like
smirked and everything um help me help you come on guys I
don't want to be here you don't want me here yeah the sooner
you answer my questions the sooner i'll be out of your
oh oh is he washing his hands wow i really actually didn't
expect that of his regulars and employees only what does it
take to become a regular how when how would you holly you're
out of paper towels and Oh,
hi.
Oh, oh, oh.
Number one or number two?
Oh, are we asking about how we...
That's terrible.
For your sake, I hope it was two.
Otherwise, you're probably shitting your pants right now.
You and me have been going at it for hundreds of years.
I'm through fighting it.
Oh.
That makes the two of us.
Well, Woody, that makes two of us.
You're in luck.
I decided to switch seats.
Hey, get your hands up.
Don't, yeah, don't F with me.
Last fella put his hand on me.
He ended up with an axe in his head.
Ugh.
Last fella I put my hand on, ended up in the ground.
Uh.
Okay, Gran.
Gran.
Go, go.
I don't know what, I don't have nothing.
Go away.
Get, get out of here.
Funny.
Just a minute ago, no one seemed to know who you were.
Yeah.
How curious is that?
Everyone got sudden amnesia.
Big bad one.
No, I'm the bad guy and you're a sheriff.
Oh.
What kind of fucking world is that, huh?
Why did you do it?
Why'd you do it?
No bullshit.
Same reason people do a lot of awful things.
Wow.
What?
Money.
I'd walk past her place for weeks.
She didn't look like it, but she had money.
I was sure of it.
She wouldn't put up any kind of fight.
Can you talk about that?
up.
In the night I finally get up the nerve to do it.
There you are.
Fucking things up for me.
You were just in the wrong place at the wrong time.
Wait, what did you do?
I wasn't there to save her.
Wait, what are you talking about?
Wasn't that his place?
Red riding on our grandmother.
Oh.
I was there to rob him.
But when I showed up, you were already there.
I thought he was talking about faith!
I only saved her.
her because I thought she might give me a reward, but she
didn't give me shit.
Except a bunch of people thinking I'm something I ain't.
I played along as long as I could.
What the heck does glass in me?
The only thing I managed to get from it was a free drink
every now and again.
Did you kill faith?
Wait, I can't tell if glass in me is like, take it and throw
it in his face, you know?
No, no, no, no.
I was here.
I swear.
look good when a girl you were just smacking around shows up
dead hours later oh she's dead bigby listen i i don't think
he did it at all i know that i hit that girl i did i i
shouldn't have but i didn't kill her you believe me right
they're gonna string me up bigby like you said it looks
fucking bad it looks really bad but i didn't do it he was
here That's the fucking truth sheriff.
How are we supposed to believe you guys?
Bigby when when you didn't even know who he was two seconds
ago.
They'll throw me down the witch and well.
That's what they'll do and I didn't do it.
You know that.
Oh, that sounds interesting exciting Hey, stop this isn't
what I want.
This guy's just shut the fuck up Woody Shit ain't just about
you.
It's about this fucking lab dog only come sniffing around
this part of town when the rich fucks and the woodlands need
a shakedown ain't that right big B you're back in the wrong
guy what does that mean lap dog lap dog I'm a lap wolf no
one gives two shits about her paperwork waiting rooms and
that bitch snow white looking right past me then usher in me
out the fucking door don't call I wouldn't call her that
don't call her that it's happened before and it doesn't end
well I didn't realize you were the bitch of the oh we got
one yeah that all you got you're the one on your pushy don't
be so sure oh it just saved oh good what is he what the heck
is this what a fable is this should have walked out of here
when you had to what the hell is a grumble you're scared
lonely don't worry about me oh she's an ogre or something oh
what's man oh shoot oh shoot oh shoot
dude not my huffs and puffs
oh shoot
Yeah.
We're getting our...
Oh gosh, we're getting our butt beat.
So I guess if you get rid of the glamour, do you have to buy
another one as seems maybe?
I want to see what Mr. Toad looks like with the glamour on.
Uh-oh.
Oh, Wiseman!
Wait, what?
Uh-oh.
The claws do be coming out.
Is this our final form or?
Kick him!
Yeah!
Oh my goodness!
We're destroying this place.
I like how...
Oh my god!
When I get into the cutscene, it puts them in place for them
to get beat up.
He's had enough!
Oh, what about when I had enough?
I could tear off his arm?
We'll walk away.
Dang.
They already think I'm like, well, I mean, nothing's going
to change their opinion.
Maybe I should have done it.
I think we're going to change their opinion of me.
Yeah, you want some of this?
You want a piece of this?
You want a piece of the wolf, man?
I chose to walk away.
With a lime.
Can you have whiskey with a lime?
Oh, she looks so sad.
Free beer tomorrow.
We're back to normal.
I guess that shows...
Send a bill to Crane.
Submit a damage report with my office.
Fable Town will pay for this.
Charge the drink on there too.
And the glass.
Don't even think about it.
You gonna run away, huh?
of treatment i can expect if i let you take me in oh run and
it'll be yeah he started it hey he started it yeah you hit
him first no i did oh well yes i did i forgot i absolutely
did hit him first that's all right i got a hundred bucks for
the first bloke that can tell me something about a girl name
uh-oh you're a little late
Who's that nerd on the wall that got banned?
Whoa!
Oh, who do I go after?
I'm gonna wolf!
I think we gotta go after this guy.
He knows more.
Fuck, man.
That's not necessary.
Shit.
He's the one.
one you want not me your brother won't be saving you this
time come on like we need to know more about his boss and
stuff right and you got nothing to worry about if we need to
know why he's looking for faith and more information on
faith I think the woodsman doesn't know anything I right he
just solicited faith maybe I think why there cops here
Do anything stupid, and I'll throw you down the witching
well myself.
That sounds like an adventure.
What's in the witching well?
Can I go?
Hello?
Oh, oh, no.
Wait, you're telling me this bar was right in front of my
house?
Was that beast?
Um, I am police.
I am police!
Oh.
What's happening?
What is it?
It's not snow white, is it?
Ah!
No!
I had a feeling when we were like, be safe.
I was like, oh, this feels like a little bit of a flag.
Oh.
completed episode one faith we had something very special oh
no snowball I knew it was gonna happen but I no where's your
brother fuck you give me one good reason I should tell you
anything oh cuz I got serial D and tweedle dumb right oh my
a serial killer oh my god and it's one of us yeah wait I'm
The woodsmen still walk in the streets.
We've got to put a lid on this.
If you can't manage it, I'll find someone who can.
I found out where she's been staying.
You shouldn't be here.
It's not safe.
You hold him?
Oh, oops.
Maybe you just want to punish someone.
We can arrange that.
I like his flaming pot.
What did you do?
The witching well.
Friend on friend.
At the end of the end.
Oh, wait, why aren't we fighting Beast?
Jesus Christ, big bleak.
Is that you?
I don't want to hear from you, Mr. Toad.
Episode 2, Smoke and Mirrors.
I wonder if you go full, you know?
If you go full fable, you then have to get another glamour.
Glamour.
You and 84% of players gave faith your money.
you would you would 14% of players tell the truth about
beast about beauty to beast I was like I'm not a part of
this and then I snitched immediately
you and 69% of players went to help Toad before Prince
Lawrence what happened to Prince Lawrence you did not
prevent his death.
We could have prevented his death.
Who is your prime suspect?
Oh, I guess this is Bluebeard.
Who the heck is this?
Wait, I don't even know who this guy is.
Uh...
Who is this?
Most people said that guy.
I don't even know who that is.
I've never seen that guy in my afterlife.
Who is that?
Who did you arrest?
When it came down to the wire, you and 68% of players made
sure Tweedledee didn't get away.
Ah, see, I think a lot of people thought the same way as me.
Wow.
O.J.
Goli.
Big B, is that you?
Are you a big, bad wolf?
I'm Toad.
Ugh.
Holy cow.
Well, awesome!
That was episode one of The Wolf Among Us.
I honestly have no idea.
I really hope that there's like I don't know.
Like, I feel like something like the woodsman is just too
boring for, you know, like, I don't know.
It feels like it's not, it's someone that we haven't met
yet.
I don't know Very cool Very cool game I'm really enjoying it
so far I'm very excited to do episode 2 And the rest But um
Yeah Thank you guys so much for watching Thank you thank you
thank you And I will catch you next time Episode 2 Very
nice, very nice Oh too Minto you guys so much!
Osubito!
Thank you so much!
See you when I see you.
Next time!
Bye!
Bye bye!
Or should we wait for the credits to go?
Wait, does that have a big foot?
Big be wolf.
Okay, I'm gonna go now.
Okay!
Bye bye!